the canon r7 one of the very few r
camera systems i'm a little unsure about
i'll tell you why when it was announced
it came out right around the same time
as the fujifilm xh2s fujifilm is known
for aps-c and medium format respectively
but aps-c first and foremost they have
the lens lineup they have the technology
they have the years of experience canon
with the r system for the most part
there's not many rf lenses and how does
the r7 fare in that regard is it worth
you investing into this camera system
what's it like compared to a fujifilm
we're going to talk about that in this
video so let's get down to it
[Music]
so before we kick things off big thanks
to canon singapore we're providing the
camera and the lenses having said that
these are my thoughts and my thoughts
only and as i talked about the r7 i was
a little bit unsure about now this comes
in our 1500 price point us dollars mind
you so you are going to have some
sacrifices made to the body design and
everything else and some features that
we're used to seeing from the r5 and the
r3 case in point the body feels a little
bit more plastic it's
not as robust as the r5 and the r3 for
that matter it is smaller
the buttons in some of the dials do feel
a little bit more plasticky they don't
feel as solid but i would say for the
most part for a 1500 camera canon's done
a pretty good job with this um the specs
inside of this i mean you've seen it
from other other videos already i'm not
going to go through everything it's a
32.5 aps-c sensor in this uh if you've
got the same autofocusing system as the
canon r3 for the most part 4k 60 i got
hlg pq something we'll put it right here
what exactly it is down samples from 7k
you get up to 30 frames per second an
electronic shutter and then 15 frames on
the mechanical shutter and you've got a
1.5 million dot
display and a 2.36 million dot evf which
is surprising in 2022 that canon would
give us not even a 3.69 but 2.36
and you do notice the difference
especially in lower light situations
bright daylight it's fine lower light it
looks grainy looks a little bit
pixelated not optimal again 1500 price
point but canon i feel personally you
could have given us at least a 3.6
million evf especially for aps-c and for
birding and wildlife photographers that
are going to utilize this camera for
that 1.6 crop that you get in aps-c that
extra resolution would help them greatly
anyway
let's talk about a little bit what it's
like to use and when i was using uh this
camera i was also testing out the xh2s
for that for the most part and the xh2s
from fujifilm is their flagship camera
at the at this point in time for the x
series lineup it is up to 40 frames per
second it does have a little bit lower
resolution at 24 megapixels versus 32.5
that's in the canon r7 but you have a
5.76 million dot evf you have an
improved autofocusing system or robust
body um it has 6k video
there's a lot of great things in that
camera system plus the lens lineup
is designed for aps-c whereas this
camera you've got this 18 to 150 here
that is an aps-c lens and they have a
few other rf aps-c lenses out there but
for the most part you're going to be
adapting full-frame lenses to this
camera which means you have to take in
that 1.6 crop factor when you are using
the system so the 2870 i have in the bag
i'll be taking out just a little bit
we're going up to the top of the cloud
for sierra gardens by the bay to take
some photos
it's not going to be 2870 it's gonna be
more like
40
90 thereabouts so those are a couple
things that gave me reservations on the
r7 but anyway what we're going to do is
we're going to go upstairs to the cloud
forest go on the bridge take some photos
with the 2870 this kit lens here as well
we're going to do some video samples go
into lightroom and i'll come back with
my final thoughts i've been using the r7
i have to say some improvements i really
like on this camera case in point
accessing video now is not a
convoluted system where you got to press
the info and go back into video versus
photo it's on the switch now so you'll
off on and go right into video mode
which is great and i think canon's
realizing people are shooting more video
as they are with the r5c and especially
the r3 and everything else but they're
making it a lot easier for people to use
that maybe this is more of a uh
entry-level camera they're trying to
make that more user-friendly but they
should do this on all their camera
systems i don't know why they didn't do
this before but i appreciate that also
we have this new dial uh joystick around
the dial here which is really
interesting i like this as well it takes
some getting used to because i'm used to
having more of a horizontal dial versus
a sort of vertical dot that you're
turning around and get your joystick in
the middle but once you do get used to
it
it's pretty intuitive and i appreciate
that the size i got larger hands the
size for me
it's a little small my pinky doesn't
have a home
no home for my pinky and i don't know if
there is an external grip for this as of
yet doesn't seem to be but you know what
by poor pinky by itself now
but uh anyway take a quick photo of this
famous instagram spot here
and then often walker so we're going to
test out the image stabilization here
with the r7 so i'm going to shoot this
waterfall here f22
one over four seconds
handheld
let's see how we fare
sharp
it's sharp
let's shoot this shot here let's kind of
cut through the water here
so it's hard for me to get
i need ng filter for this
this is one over five
f twenty
this is impressive
this image stabilization
is amazing
one over five f twenty iso 100 handheld
with one hand because i'm holding this
in my other hand and the image is sharp
another feature on the r7 is hdrpq um
another format that might not be
compatible with all your computer
systems so do check it out before you
start utilizing it but basically what it
does is it gives you a lot of dynamic
range in your image
and it's pretty good
kind of gives you more of a flatter
feel
to your image and then of course you can
grade it but when you put it into
lightroom or capture one it looks decent
but
out of camera it kind of looks a little
bit
yeah kind of like what you get out of a
smartphone but nowadays that's what
people like right right also there's
panoramic mode as well i'm trying to
figure out where that's at here on this
the is
system you just kind of move
left and right
try again and keep camera moving
precisely in the direction shown so it's
a bit picky this thing is a bit picky
and because
i'm on a 28
and
the crop factor i'm not getting this
super wide shot let me try one more time
yeah it's pretty good not bad at all
not bad all and of course you can go all
the way to the end or you can stop it
however you want to do it so it stitches
it up for you so if you want a panoramic
shot i don't know why you really can't
put panoramic on instagram or facebook
but if you want it for some reason
it's in the camera
[Music]
i mean this camera is impressive it does
really good and of course you have to
give a lot of credit to the rf lenses
from canon which are fantastic lenses
fightingly sharp
great rendering zero chromatic
aberration distortion i mean they build
some of the best mirrorless lenses on
the market so paired with this 32.5
aps-c sensor this is a very formidable
camera out there again now if you're
comparing it to other aps-c cameras on
the market if you want to compare to
sony sony and canon are kind of in the
same boat they don't have a lot of
native aps-c lenses so you're relying on
either third-party uh vendors for sony
for that matter but canon not so much or
you're reliant on adapting full frame
lenses to the aps-c sensor which means
that crop factor comes into play this is
where i think fujifilm still has the
edge with the xh2s and the x-series over
the r7 is that they have a lot more
native lenses primes zooms the full
array of aps-c lenses that are going to
take advantage of the size of the camera
the weight
and balance it out a little bit better
than what we're seeing from canon of
course i've got this 2870 f2 which is a
massive lens but even let's say you want
to do the 50 1.2
or the 85 one two those are very large
lenses and to the small body i don't
know exactly how they'll match up for a
lot of people out there again
this is something that canon probably in
the near future will adapt lenses if the
r7 the r10 do very well they'll probably
come out with more smaller lenses you
know 1.4 1.8 f2s out there to sort of
compensate for the size and i hope they
do but it depends on how much they want
to invest in the system or are they just
looking at this r7 as a a b camera for
wildlife and birding photographers or
sporting photographers out there that
want that extra length they'll put it
onto a monopod and they'll just shoot
that way and they don't care i don't
know it means to be seen but in terms of
video i think it's a great camera for
vloggers out there for youtubers out
there you can be very happy with this
photographers you're going to like the
image quality out of it and especially
some of the new features so i do like
the r7 but they need some lenses
badly anyway those are my thoughts on
the camera let me know your thoughts in
the comment section below subscribe to
the channel we've got always new content
coming your way
like this video hit that notification
bell stay safe and i'll chat to you soon
take care
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you